um
[Music]
there we go
to the realest podcast in the dunya
the three muslims
we are here with the home base at the
home base
how are you guys
bro
guys
right before we begin because we want to
keep it semi-professional
let us know if you can hear us clearly
if there's any issues
audio video lighting anything at all
just let us know
so guys
did we ever think we would get this far
no
no
i didn't no me neither bro i think we
should talk about how we started bro
let's do it bro recap on it let's talk
about it
yeah
i mean i've already said the story many
times bro so any of you want to do the
honors it's had a lot
you guys you guys met first though
yeah the the origin story when i called
you that night
all right my shout out so
i'm just chilling at home i'm sitting at
home i don't know what i was doing i was
busy eating something right i got a call
from this guy if i had i'm like okay
this is weird random where hold on
yeah
let's see everything perfect it's super
clean some people are saying it's super
clean
loud and clear we can't hear on her we
got one
on his mic not working that's two guys
can you hear on hell no
it says anil's mic is low can't hear him
okay i see i see
yeah our insider says microphones sound
amazing
thank you yeah what about
what about my
technical difficulties
technical difficulties
okay yeah his mic ain't working
okay guys can you hear me
yes or no can you hear me
other two mics are perfect okay
he said his voice is there but it's just
low
you can turn the knob
the knob on the audio interface
yeah okay not the actual mic
can you guys you don't know
we hear
[Music]
his mic is off we can hear him from like
every time
you see
this i'm not seeing an issue with
[Music]
they said we hear on her through the
other mics yeah yeah
yeah okay okay well is this
this might extend bro i could send it to
him when when it's he's going to speak
about
guys listen
please be patient all right we're just
we're figuring things out still
um
july 1st
in-person podcast will begin as you see
all three of us together for the force
evil future insha allah but until then
just bear with this livestream this is
our first time all right man god bless
you guys i mean all right
how about now y'all
no for real
still nothing
i think this might be the faulty no
change
faulty
mic could be i mean we can get it fixed
up bro yeah
okay
how about
when you when you're speaking you can
share with me
you can share with me for today
all right bismillah okay guys with that
being said
without further ado if you made it this
far smash this like button before we go
into story time
158 viewers
then uh we should have at least 600
likes inshaallah let's go
it might just be the audio interface
i mean you don't want to speak like this
it bro it only catches my audio when i
put it max max really yeah
like the other one was like watch look
speed but
it was good
guys this is the sure sm7b the hottest
mics in the game so i don't know what's
going on
new too
so inshallah broken
connection
yeah
just gonna put it here
inshaallah okay
let's begin bro
all right
so yeah one random night i get a call
from five to like 9 p.m 10 p.m it's late
maybe later
i was eating chilling doing something i
was busy uh and he's like hey you know i
have uh this guy we're trying to give
dawah to on a call here and i have
another guy another muslim brother just
reverted not too long ago
you know what do you jump on and kind of
help out here you know discuss and talk
with this guy i'm like
why not and let's do it insha allah
so i hop on the zoom call i see angel
for the first time
like masha'allah good looking brother
nice smile on his face masha'allah see
if i item
may allah bless him
beautiful brother as well
and then i see the brother who i don't
know maybe i should have mentioned name
but
the brother that they were trying to
give dawah to at the time
and we just started going in we just
started chatting talking it's a nice
long proper conversation and then you
know whatever happened with the call
happen and then after the call
we all had a group call and we just
started chatting just talking
who came up with the idea
because it sprung to someone's head
i honestly can't even remember
did you
join it was a joint effort guys
[Music]
that's the origin story bro
uh at least that's that's the
filtered origin story yeah
aside from this man i'm gonna pass this
mic over to unhealth so he could speak
i'm gonna
move his a little bit out of the way
inshaallah
okay i'm gonna send you this one right
now
and i'm gonna bro him some questions bro
so we can get some air time
okay let me get this airtime y'all hear
me now
yeah y'all hear me now write your name
first question is
he's like that we're going to have the
asmr sessions real soon inshallah
yeah so the way the way we met
i uh when i lived in mississauga i went
to crunchy gym i just walk in one day
and i'm a newbie i'm not a pretty built
guy you know i like these villagers my
village masha'allah they're very bold so
i go to the gym don't really know what
i'm doing been there a few times talk to
a few people and i see this guy doing
tricep extensions trash up pull downs
and i'm like i want to get in on that
so i go to him like hey
can you show me how to do that you know
work it out properly sometimes when i do
it i feel it in my shoulders i don't
think i'm doing it right
so he shows me how to do it on allah
and uh i think something like i say
alhamdulillah he slips out he's like oh
you're a muslim i'm like yeah yeah you
he's like yeah i'm like masha allah
i go to the gym another time to take a
picture of the brother
for his ig
and then after that he invites me to go
on a trip to vance alberta
and i'm like you know what let's do it
let's do it which was also documented
you guys can find that
i thought you all feel like a parent
oh we got too many how old are all of
y'all
i know
how many times have we actually said
this
okay
um romney is you're 21 yeah you're
turning 22 in romney's turning 22 real
soon inshallah
is 24 right
if i was 24 and i am 28 alhamdulillah
no no there's no action
[Laughter]
game well
tell them
so i'm from mississauga fight actually
you were from toronto right
yeah then you moved to mississauga fire
just not fired angels from uh
the americas
on an episode of freshly ground in the
uk and when he mentioned that you guys
are starting out and now i shall look
great to see how
it's amazing it really is yes it is
how does angel feel about canada that's
a good question i'll i'll be honest
i was selling this to the brothers
um at first i i really thought canada
was gonna be ass i thought it wasn't
gonna be good
yeah but uh it's a pleasant surprise it
really is it's a pleasant surprise very
beautiful
um
i did check out mississauga area we have
yet to check out
toronto or the hamilton area um niagara
falls area very beautiful as well
um but
overall very pleasantly surprised
what is that
wait who's that alpha from the wolf pack
they they just asking who's the alpha
what are you talking about
so technically he's a leader
be all over the world
[Music]
says congratulations brothers may allah
bless you for your efforts
oh you want me to read that i was
watching oh they want the asmr action
yeah okay
um i was watching
when i was struggling with anxiety and
became spiritual i reverted to islam in
2019 then in 2000
twenty he reverses
it's crazy how things work huh
as i haven't picked up hockey yet nope
oh
osmose remember i was telling you the
chicken on the rocks yeah yeah with the
garlic sauce that's it bro
uh is this temporary y'all relocated um
tell them that
it's permanent but we're gonna be upping
it as things
[Music]
stay tuned
the bluffs
scarborough bluffs i think that's what
they just said yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah it's really nice masha'allah
we've got some nice kanafi down there
again
hawaii
man i bless you
welcome to the fam
where's the sign going right above
fire's head
love from
as a as a beijing
as obviously
in person it's probably too busy though
first real question bro
thoughts
on andrew tate
and if you could would you get him on
y'all's backpack podcast
wrong what you think honestly yeah
honestly yeah i think
i like a lot of what he says obviously i
don't agree with everything he says and
a lot of the time he's a showman right
and i can't respect that you know
everyone a lot of people are showing the
best personalities online are show men
people are really uh praising him
nowadays i think a lot of the stuff he
preaches is really good he clearly has
some nice beautiful views on islam
to islam my brother had him on the
podcast recently gave him a copy of the
quran which was really nice i would love
to have him on the podcast inshaallah
one day and ask why he's not a muslim
yet
yeah
i i personally i really like the brother
i like his message
um i just think that
you know since he is
not muslim since he doesn't have that
that proper structure that the
guidelines of islam he knows what islam
is he knows the structure of islam he
even
uh
admits that like that's that rigidity is
what we need in today's day
and um
since he's not operating from that a lot
of things that he does say like i i
don't really hold it against him
because it's like you know this is how i
would have seen it as well to be 100
honest
but may allah bless him because he's
he's getting there
what's what y'all doing there we go
we're accommodating boy because your mic
not working
let's check it one more time
we ain't doing that today bro we're
going then uh my honest thoughts of uh
will star the andrew no i'm just playing
maybe one day bro
who knows
where someone can end up
uh insha allah gets there but my my
honest thoughts and you know i was
tuning in to andrew tate a little bit
before the podcast upstairs and my
honest thoughts are that he's a very
smart man and when you look at a lot of
individuals today right that are
non-muslim they don't have the
instruction manual that we keep talking
about on our podcast right the playbook
that allah has given us and best out as
a mercy so my honest thoughts is as
somebody who doesn't have that from what
i know
he's still far better off in terms of
ideologies and and just being awakened
than the average person
but because he doesn't have the
guidelines he makes mistakes just like a
lot of people do just like we all do
ourselves we're not perfect no one's
perfect
but i believe his life can only be much
better if he does have that so inshallah
i got him to islam
but what i did have to say about him is
i don't know too much about business
about him and business so i don't know
if he's a businessman but what i do know
is he's a really good influencer in
terms of marketing himself and social
media and positioning
so i do think a huge reason why he got
to the top
and i'm talking like followers and subs
lately was not per se about his business
or his brand but his personal brand and
how he markets himself and he's really
good at that bro
okay oh no this is the first time we met
it's the first time that i meet romney
it's the first time all three of us have
been together in the same room
let's say that
andrew tate hacked the youtube algorithm
70 of the youtube stories i see from him
subhanallah
okay let's see
oh we got a lot of a lot of comments it
is also
like what you view
is what youtube throws at you so if you
started viewing some of the andrew
tate's stuff then youtube's gonna throw
that at you just like if you started
searching up some random thing on
youtube like let's say how to build a
shelf well now youtube's gonna throw
some random things of how to build
shelves at you
it's my rocky inshallah
when are you guys coming to montreal
have you ever been to montreal so rami's
never been to montreal
i've been a couple of times
you've you've obviously never been how
far is montreal from here
uh given that
is there not far enough bro
six hours six to seven hours if we just
mention it
that's pretty far
but but it's like a day trip bro
that's pretty far
i mean let's let's reach out to him
inshallah and we'll see what happens
mm-hmm inshallah yusuf writes when is
iman gaji coming on the stream if he
does ask him why he ain't one yet
inshallah so guys if you know who he is
go on his socials go on his instagram go
on his youtube just just spam come on
the three muslims we've reached out to
him he reached out back to us and he's
down but you know people get busy so
inshallah give him a reminder
okay i'll do a few more and i'll pass
this mic back to rami when are you
coming to the uk brothers
uh
stay tuned stay tuned
stay tuned
okay odd question no username
did you just ask us have we tried
pancakes with banana
i want you to ask what i mean this is a
good idea
i'm going to spell my name wrong by the
way
uh you should visit jane and finch area
what what is that that's the most ghetto
ratchet ends in the six
yeah yes
if he visits there bro everyone's gonna
be forced into submission bro
oh no do you still train any form of mma
uh currently i am recovering from
injuries
so if you could i would greatly
appreciate you making dua
for me to heal up
and yeah
that's where i'm at
um we got a comment from vladimir putin
i hope the clout and success doesn't
change you guys insha allah may allah
make you make us as you see us
stick to the quran in sunnah and the way
of the salaf yes
are you all living together
at the moment at the moment yeah yeah at
the moment yeah see where life takes us
but just just know july 1st first
episode in person
proper edits multiple camera angles the
whole nine yards and you will get one
every friday
forever insha allah follows it
just picture this you got this straight
on view
and then out of nowhere it's just going
to cut into like romney
and then it's going to cut into me they
supported the channel and we show them
what we got
we've got the legit
camera
closest cameron charlotte so we can show
that we only need one yeah we got a
couple of these
uh sony a mirrorless cameras you know i
don't i don't say this to flex i say
this because you guys supported us
and supported the studio and the
development
and all this other all the donations
you've given us we're just showing you
you know receipts we don't want to you
know act like you know i did anything
else with the money and truth be told
guys we're left with basically nothing
like this this is something that that
you know i don't know we didn't plan
this that we're going to talk about this
but you know all the money that we
raised alhamdulillah through all of your
lovely support we've dropped everything
on the podcast and
this i would say we found the perfect
bounce between not getting cheap
equipment that's gonna break and we have
to keep buying it except for this one
right here we'll talk about that after
and also not getting stuff too expensive
that's boujee you know we don't need
that so we got decent sony mirrorless
cameras we got a couple of them for
different camera angles too
we got nice backgrounds we got the nice
mics we got warranty for the mics guys
so don't worry we'll figure out what
happened to on ho's sm7b inshallah but
aside from that uh we are getting a neon
sign which is going to be behind us
inshallah so i'm looking forward to that
okay get the likes up in sha allah
how many people we got watching right
now we got 200 people
boy that's like 600 likes we should have
that's that's 650 right now
okay
next night studio brothers
and mr mr
salam
we still haven't gotten y'all's address
no no they gave it to me bro oh
read it with an open mind it's a clear
quran you know recommended by uh brother
rami insha allah should be good and
check your tic tac diems
all right next uh
to see you three in the same room is
unreal bro
listen it's unreal for all of us yeah we
still didn't even get yeah yeah
okay last one and i'll pass it on me on
her versus mohammed hijab who wins what
do you think bro tell them tell them
yeah you're talking about mma are you
talking about like on a debate because
he'll win a debate all day
in a fight i've never seen him fight
i've never seen him train
he'd probably get he might get me with
the wrestling because he's a big man
yeah he's like six
six six six seven
and how much he weighs like two 280 to
300.
geez nah but i'm like 140 something no
no it's it's gonna be a tough tough
grappling fight if me and him go ahead
[Music]
mr muslim is just starting his mma
career
may allah
got some food spa so listen i'm down
i'm down
i've been listen i've been in in the
hoods in florida and puerto rico we have
this one place called la pella
and la pella is like yo you know that uh
music video despacito yeah it's like
very famous they they filmed in the spot
with like a whole bunch of different
colors like the different colored
buildings just like that that spot is
the hood in san huang and viejo san juan
is called la pella and bro like people
go in there and they go missing
yeah like most of the most of the people
that travel to pr and they end up like
going going missing is is there in the
pillar
are you gay
i'm just playing i'm just like no are
you are you lebanese
because we
currently we have this microphone here
that don't work too good
so we are sharing two mics between three
of us
yeah so i'm about to be the quiet one
real soon
it's a salam brothers congrats what are
your ethnicities
i'm
and a brother angel when he spoke about
pr he's talking about puerto rico he's
puerto rican masha'allah
which
scholars do you guys usually listen to
yeah that's a good question it's a good
question i have my my shaykh here
in mississauga um
that's my my main go-to i guess it's
alhamdulillah there are many amazing out
there you know imam malik allah he said
that the madhhab
of the layman the school of thought for
the layman is his shaykh
i guess teach their own in that case how
about you
[Laughter]
because well brothers and sisters here
on this path
but if i had to really say about shakes
um
one shake in particular that i've been
listening to is um
hey proper brother bro i like his stuff
who want to see the uk trip with the
cadburys
[Laughter]
yeah i think there's light too strong on
me bro i think it's fine bro
because my brightness is really oh okay
whatever you what are your views on
women who go into careers such as a
doctor
or dentist and if they can balance
family life
you wanna go first bro necessary because
when your wife's giving birth you want a
man to deliver or a woman if you have
the choice
something to consider you know if you
have someone operating this facts you
know doing dentures work in your wife's
mouth and your mother's mouth and your
sister's mouth would you prefer it's a
man or a woman
now can they balance it allah i remember
i'm not the one to answer i don't know
how difficult it is to be a doctor um
whether you're in a hospital you're in a
walking clinic if you're in the
dentistry
if they can may allah bless them reward
them for
[Music]
yeah
fire said he's agreeing
fayette
how did you prepare for your bio 2403
exam
go ahead
let's check this
i think that mic is fine it's just the
settings on the computer with the
interface that's it
so now i'm alaikum boys cause you guys
hear me inshallah you can there's
there's way too many comments right now
to go through to even see what you guys
are going to say so vietnam you can hear
me now
how did i prepare for my bio not 2403
2803 but it's probably the glare do you
know what this is bro
this is a
a course
about animal animal physiology bro
biology course
intimacy kind of bro see physiology is
very important for intimacy
but this was more about like the
systemic physiology you know like the
body systems
you got the the endocrine system you got
the circulatory system the basic stuff
right but it goes a little bit in depth
how do i prepare for the exam
um just like i would prefer for any
other exam you know go over the readings
go over the slides
uh learn to learn not memorize to learn
you know or learn to memorize
retain the information understand the
concepts and
i'm going to give y'all a tip right now
all
right
pause on before you say anything
this tip is going to be about how to
succeed in university in general all
right for people that are struggling
you want to go to your teachers
and you never want to ask them directly
like what's going to be on the test
what's going to be on the midterm what's
going to be on the exam they're never
going to answer it so what you do is you
ask what are the most important things
or takeaways that i need to know
you frame it in a way to show like what
are the most important comprehensive
concepts so you ask someone that's
saying chemistry you got an exam coming
up
what are the most important things i
need to know from this unit
they'll take importance as obviously
things that are heavily weighted and
valued on the exams
and they'll tell you that because you
know they're not allowed to not tell you
that right but you're not directly
asking what questions are going to be on
the exams you ask what's most important
to know they'll tell you this this and
that is most important to know you study
mainly those things and you go in on
those right if something is not heavily
composed on the exam you don't need to
know but if something's really important
then i would recommend going in on that
inshallah
anno just make sure you avoid church
street
i don't know what's what's in church
street bro oh you're talking about
orlando
and orlando they got church street
that's like
cars
you surprised mo hijab is a big boy
[Laughter]
yo i thought rami was sure and also
didn't expect bro uh this to be
happening well here's the thing a lot of
people think around me i don't know why
because anytime they they talk to me and
they're just like how tall is around me
they're just like yo rami is the
youngest one he's the shortest one i
don't know where they got there rami is
the tallest one masha'allah if you all
saw the first
scene of him just squashing those people
and and baal mashallah but uh he's the
tallest one
angel is the second tallest i'm the
shortest
six seven i'm thinking
[Music]
oh goku doesn't believe you that you're
140 pounds bro
uh yeah right now
maybe like 140 147 150 right now
definitely
just say alphabet bro well i'll read it
up how do you guys approach family or
cousins who post pro alphabet stuff
off of beginning stuff
rainbow gang stuff on social media we
are muslim
what do you think
uh you just talk to them you just
obviously go in with good character and
be honest but not brutally honest and
just tell them what's up tell them
listen we're muslim
you're muslim alhamdulillah
okay so you know in islam allah says
this and that right and join god and
forbid evil we know that it's a sin we
know that supporting it is also sinful
because of what allah tells us and what
the messenger ali islam says so we know
we can't endorse it we can't support it
does that mean we have to go and have
anti lgb i mean alphabet gang rallies we
don't have to we don't have to hate them
we can live amongst them there's no
issue with that just supporting them is
actually potentially taking you out of
the fold of islam so just educate them
kindly and if they don't listen
say salaam alaikum and walk away
that's bro mashallah that's a good
answer very succinct bro i gotta learn
that skill sometimes i i spend too long
on one question but ami's over here just
giving the most important stuff masha
allah okay before i put the next
question i'm just gonna put you guys on
mute for like 10 seconds
any thoughts on fresh and fit especially
one of one of them acting muslim when a
physical narrative this is a message
that i have just a general genuine
nasiha genuine advice
to
[Music]
myron gaines even though that's not even
his name uh the guy on fresh and fit one
of them
and to uh
andrew tate
a lot of these people have been noticing
that islam has been right on intersexual
dynamics
when the west has not been
the mainstream
blue pill
ghana centric advice so to speak
and what they tend to do a lot of them
is they
almost
make it a trend or a fad to say muslim
things
say you know four wives or this or that
you know and i get it bro it's it's cool
and all but at the end of the day in
islam the most important thing is akida
so these people that are not having the
belief of being muslim they haven't
accepted being muslim but they almost
memified if that's even a word the
muslim culture and the muslim identity
just to get their points just to use
this as like a trump card in a way where
it's like you know why are you doing
this you're supposed to be covered up
well why are you living a life where
you're creating more women like that
right no one talks about that side
so this general message that i'm giving
out to
maybe the manosphere the red pill
community whatever it is the youtubers
that are here
using islam to promote something that
is not centric to islam
and they're only too consumed with one
side of the coin
i think it's it's immature
but it's also dangerous
because you're too
i guess lopsided or you're too like
you know biased into what you're saying
that you're missing the other person's
point of view yeah so to speak very true
yeah
yeah and subhanallah there's a lot of
muslim youtubers doing this too not to
name any names but may allah protect us
from that
i'm sure
i'm gonna reach with them
i got i got small bengali hands bro come
on now come on now you know this is
locked up
no you're good bro uh muhammad you know
what we're not talking about house
weight anymore guys come on this is you
guys are you skinny [ __ ] with him
now
come on
he's leaned over
[Music]
and
less body fat
okay
next question i want all three of us to
answer even though anjo's technically
the only reaver here
maybe they didn't never know
says suzanne albright what is the
biggest change you would say you noticed
about yourself let's see yourselves
after practicing islam so i know why
don't you go first actually you know
what for the sake of the mic you go
first then i go then we'll pass it on
man
sis
sister uh there have been so many big
changes in my life i can't just say name
one you know there's my entire life has
changed from the way i live it's the way
i perceive life what my perspective is
my confidence even my character my my
livelihood what i would consider to be a
good job versus what i know is a bad job
um
and anything that's not haram you know
it's halal it's good it's
subhan allah everything changes for you
and that's the most beautiful part
because you realize how little you know
and you realize how
lost you would have been without islam
now so i'm just very grateful that allah
has guided me
and may allah continue to guide us bro i
mean
um
okay for me
i'm gonna keep it short and simple
because you asked the biggest change so
one of the biggest things all right this
is not by far the number one biggest
thing but this is one of the most
pivotal things in my life that has taken
a shift after i've become muslim is the
ego all right i cannot i cannot joke
about how
severely my ego has impacted my decision
making
my choices
my
regrettable mistakes in my life
and how wrong i was about so many things
and one who is too caught up in an ego
and there's no islam in their life
they submit their will to their ego they
make the decisions based on their ego
their own subjective understanding of
the world however when you come to islam
you understand there's so much that i
don't know and and the more you study
islam the more you realize you don't
know anything right so you kind of strip
this mentality away from your mind where
you know everything and everyone else is
wrong and you realize you got to be
humble because there's so much that you
don't know
and it really does
you know there's there's a saying if if
i get what i want out of life i say
alhamdulillah once and then if i don't
get what i want i say alhamdulillah
twice because when i don't get what i
want the color of allah
and allah's infinite hikma and wisdom
is is what's going to be you know
deciding what's going to happen not what
i want all the time necessarily
so the question is
what is the biggest change that you
would say you notice about yourself
after practicing islam
um
damn that's
i'll keep it simple
i'll say that it's um more awareness
you know as obviously the taqwa is the
god consciousness
but it's it's a sense where it's like i
had awareness before but i didn't know
how to handle it now that i am a muslim
like i have this awareness and i better
know how to handle things where it's
like when things are getting maybe like
really stressful and
maybe i don't have the answer maybe i
don't know what to do maybe i don't have
the money maybe i don't have this or
that it's like i always know
that everything is going to be all right
like allah always provides and
you know he he gives everything and if
you look back in your life
allah is taking care of y'all you know
like a lot of taking care of us allah
take care of everyone
and as long as you have faith in that
and trust in that like then it will be
and it it will be even if you don't
that's a crazy thing so it's like it's a
test in and of itself but
um to keep it simple just the awareness
people have no idea how hard it is
to come up with quality video content
mr muslim now knows no no official
100
100
you know nissan means woman that's a
sister right there that that is not
possible we cannot we cannot hug right
now for allah
[Laughter]
i'm just playing guys
how was it converting to islam and
finding out
we use water to clean after
uh
i didn't believe it at first
yeah bro romney fire told me this and i
was like bro that's disgusting like why
would y'all do that and he's like no no
he's trying to tell me that like
uh was it was the um the brother y'all
see
no we're not yasir what the hell am i
saying um yeah yeah
yeah yeah was
he was talking about the the doo-doo
like on the table like if you're using
paper it's like you're just
smearing it versus when you use water
you're like actually cleaning it up
but man like
when i first i was like what the
heck no wonder y'all don't like use the
hand left hand you know
shout out
to my brother who i've never met
my love bless you bro
i mean
oof heavy question bro
they are asking when are we going to
visit mecca together
that's a dream
yeah
soon man
[Music]
inshallah
this is a good question
any advice
for brothers who want to grow
a beard
but their parents are forcing them to
shave or keep it short
damn
that's tough
um
firstly teach your parents to tell them
why you want to grow it that's very
important
and
honestly it's my honest opinion if they
don't budge and they want you to go to a
shaykh and ask because every situation
is specific you know
i don't know
i don't know the ruling on it i can't
say it's halal to shave haram to shave
some scholars a different opinion on
whether it's foreign to begin with i
follow the opinion that it is just to be
safe um i would say honestly discuss
with the sheikh and set your parents
down this year as well
um
i agree
yeah
i don't know man
i still don't use the water to be honest
with you this guy
all right
uh actually let's do two more
oh yeah i gotta read it off
question
salamu
um what's your advice on looks in
marriage for a man for a woman
yeah that's that's
people will act like there's no
difference there is a humongous
difference between men and women and
looks and how they because a man can be
hot to a woman without like you know
being
you know
conventionally attractive like women
will be like he's ugly hot
i've heard that before like he's ugly
hot like he's unconventionally
attractive not just in the way he looks
the way he acts the way he behaves his
demeanor oh there's so many things
that a woman will look at for it man for
a guy it's i think a very standard what
guys generally find attractive pleasing
to that yeah pleasing to the eye but
there is a deeper level all right that
has to do with character
how feminine she is if she is willing to
let you be the man be dominant
that is very very important
yeah so before we change the question do
you have anything to add i want to throw
something
there's a lot of marriage relationships
intimacy episodes
yeah so far that we have a lot of
marriage and intimacy episodes coming in
inshallah so stay on the lookout for
that now what i wanted to add to this
question
is um in terms of looks just a piggyback
half wrong if you remember that
uh
looks are important
looks are very important actually
because even though looks fake
if you look at your partner
before you actually you know
get married to them and you say masha
allah
even when the looks fade you will still
say masha allah now of course granted
like they have the character
and they have the dean and they have all
this stuff
but you you want to look at your partner
and you want to be attracted to what you
see because if there is no attraction
then i'm sorry but
good luck
okay
it's the same question
bro i was about to say in the same exact
way question
you
know brother asked this question so many
times who is like every every three just
spamming bro oh don't spam bro come on
now put you on the table i'll have to
block you important questions bro i
don't know where it is now oh this stuff
do you remember what it was yeah it was
my reverb
what is the purpose of salah
why do you guys pray well i mean if you
look at why we do anything right first
and foremost allah tells us to do it and
allah has made it obligatory right
there's a beautiful hadith where the
prophet hadith meaning he starts by
saying allah the most high has said so
although it's a hadith where the process
is speaking he's basically narrating
what allah said so he says
the most high
basically says that the most beloved
acts of worship to me
are the ones which i made obligatory
meaning the ones that allah says you
have to do them he loves them the most
and then allah says that the servant
continues to get closer and closer to
allah with voluntary acts of good until
allah begins to love him it's a
beautiful hadith it goes on but the
point is the salah here you can look at
it in many different ways right salah
linguistically means connection
and it was given to the prophet the
hukum the ruling was given to the
prophet by allah himself to the prophet
on the night journey right
that one on one connection no messenger
angel
so there is that connection right you
can look at it like that kind of
metaphorically it's very beautiful and
when we pray it's a connection between
us
so it's very beautiful so you could say
that is to establish a good connection
with allah now there's two ways i want
to answer that might seem conflicting
but they're not if you think about it
firstly we pray because allah is worthy
of worship and because allah tells us to
allah is grand
he deserves to be worshipped
just by
being allah but it's not for him it
doesn't help allah it is actually for us
and if you look at someone who prays and
someone who doesn't pray
or yourself when you used to pray or
when you you know used to not pray and
vice versa
and how your life is changed how much
more of a clear head you have it is a
huge blessing so you could see many
different hikmah wisdoms and blessings
behind the salah
do you still want four wives
and do you hope to get married before
30.
so i want whatever allah has decreed for
me said this in a different podcast a
different live stream actually someone
has a very similar question
um i'll be honest you know i'll be
honest and admit fault that when i first
came into islam
i was still very jihad i'm still very
jihad you know allah knows best
but
when i came into islam i was under the
impression of like okay well
i'm gonna fulfill my desires in a lot of
way
so i'm gonna have four wives
and
i'm not even gonna say what i tell y'all
i'm joking around because i want to be
serious i want to be
legit
um
i personally see having multiple wives
as something that should only be done
like for the sake of allah you know if
it's for your nafs if it's for your
desires then there's really no reason
for it it's like allah says in the quran
like
if you can't be just
with two three four then only have one
and if you can't be just with one then
don't even have one you know then be
chess be um celebrity or uh
did i get that correct yeah
and i think that's very important
because if you are just doing it for
your naps
then you will never be able to be just
with two three or four but if allah is
guiding you
and you married one and then you pray to
sahada and allah specifically gave you
the sign like no marry this woman help
this woman out or you're to be able to
be just with her and treat her fairly
because
it's all for the sake of allah
yo
so not only was that a super good answer
bro
but people have been writing about this
will we ever see a gsp podcast since
you're in canada you and brother faraz
can make it happen bro imagine we meet
where we invite them bro
you know jsp
yeah i think it happened bro
that'd be dope
next question
i'm 14 years old and already studying
how christianity is wrong
you got it you got a 10 year
head start on all of us so
use that because knowledge doesn't come
to everyone subhanallah
aisha writes did anger visit niagara
falls
not yet but stay tuned guys we will
insha allah
probably even right after this vlog uh
right after this live stream who knows
if allah was
but links in the description down below
for the vlog that we did so far behind
the scenes of setting the podcast up but
also
we might make a vlog of niagara falls
who knows bro inshallah
memo writes a bad personality can turn a
pretty face ugly what do you guys think
about that
do you think about the opposite too that
uh
good personality can make an ugly face
pretty
okay that's what my mom tells me that's
what your mom tells you yeah why should
i tell you that bro you got a good face
and a good uh personality
next
50k soon inshallah congrats guys we
already know um based on the analytics
we reached this by tonight so i just
wrote 50k why not
49.99
like this video please
leave a comment down below you know on
the live chat and when it's done share
this with your with your homies
you know it helps promote it with your
grandma with your grandma to you give me
grandma videos man
do you speak
any other language
i speak
spanish
i speak
english
i speak portuguese
i speak
those are the ones i'm like okay so it's
english most fluent no no spanish most
women
english second most fluent third is uh
portuguese then
a little bit of arabic
um a little bit of french i'm learning
inshallah
um and a little bit of thai just very
very basic
okay
okay i speak uh english
bengali right bengali was my first
language bangla but i do because of that
understand and speak a little bit about
the other desi languages
hindi urdu punjabi all
[Music]
will you guys do a fan meetup in toronto
i hate that word fan bro
yeah
it's shirky
which at least feels like that he
probably didn't mean this i know i know
but it just it makes me feel you know
we're all brothers and sisters in islam
we're equal we will
we've been talking about it about having
the meet up but right now you know we
just got together
we're just now
finishing this studio as you can see
it's not done yet it's got something way
better like just wait just marshall i
just wait july 1st and then from there
like we'll start getting into the other
stuff like i said
stay tuned
goku writes your fight
yeah bro with the doll part you already
know
i think i think none of these two know
what i'm talking about elish mas is a
type of fish bro it's a fish curry i
know you like fish curry
we brought them to my house mela bless
my parents but you know they made some
nice barbecue and and some nice fish but
it wasn't like desi daisy fish you know
like the curry
you know so exactly
you got the aloo the the potatoes
well game over bro
maybe you're right yo they finally met
let's go yes
i wish we had all three mics working
mm-hmm inshallah bro by next week
it's crazy bro cuz like this one
this one will catch on here and i'll
keep seeing the light pop on
so it's a shame bro
okay guys we're gonna wrap this up real
quick in a few minutes inshaallah allah
thank you so last couple of questions
real quickly the answer
reel it up boy
let's see
how y'all work out when the gyms have
half naked women men and music
okay first off
is this a woman or is this a man asking
this question
no just just let us know it might just
be a man so i will
i will assume there's a man
most of the women that go to the gym
ain't that attractive
[Laughter]
i mean they're in the gym for a reason
and it's not me trying to like throw
dirt on them
but like
next time you're at the gym like
i can't say that because i'm i'm then
i'm like telling them like oh take a
heart take a good look
listen listen listen for real though
like
um
the women aren't that attractive
it's just what they're wearing that
makes it seem
like they're trying to because it's it's
it's it's
highlighting their features
right but if you actually like looked at
them and i'm not advising you to do this
because obviously we should advise to
lower our gears
but
they're not that attractive
yeah
and when you go to the gym like you
should have one
goal
and that is to
do whatever it is that you have to do in
the gym and if it's really that big of a
deal if you really can't focus
call us don't go to the gym
go work outside like do work outside get
some gymnastic rings um i don't know get
get creative with it there's so much
that can be done
you guys want to take five more
questions insha'allah and then we're
going to wrap it up
yeah let romney get i'm going to give
this to rami
you want to take this one both of you
yeah
i got y'all
[Laughter]
uh why is it loose now tighten it up are
you turning
over here
all right
i can't turn into a bro
i might just i might just i might just
hold it like this guys but jazakallah
for uh you know really tuning in and and
you know having subur with us setting up
for the first time this has been a very
uh journey for all of us
and insha allah you know looking forward
to
july 1st guys july 1st the first real in
person podcast drops multiple cameras
angles
audio that works seamlessly inshallah
right nothing like today uh professional
edits we got editors on the team so
insha'allah stay tuned for that every
single friday starting july 1st 2022 you
will get a new brand new episode
a lot of topics inshallah and we want to
keep it engaging with the community
permissively so let us know if you guys
have any requests for topics and we will
consider them carefully if they're
important and needed in the community
just hopped in mashallah y'all look
fresh may allah make us as you see us
bro
nice to see you all together in one
place
let's see
my parents want me to get married but
i'm not ready yet but i don't want to
disappoint them what i do
um
if you're not ready to get married don't
get married
if you're not ready to get married don't
get married because you're going to ruin
not just your life but someone else's
life and don't let your parents ruin
your life in someone else's life if you
have to tell them
uh listen it's not happening i don't
like if they can get mad right they're
gonna get mad they're gonna do whatever
they're gonna do it's it's better to
suffer five years of them being mad at
you for not being married and suffer the
rest of your life because you've gone to
a marriage too early um plus someone
else's life plus kids as well there are
so many things to consider so just have
a nice proper discussion bring a check
if you need to to tell them listen if
they're not ready to get married they
cannot get married or they should not
get married and have the sheikh
inshallah they won't listen to
because this is this is serious like
there have been so many unfortunately
mainly women but it happens to men as
well who are pushed to getting married
and they get married and then they ruin
their life and someone else's life and
their kids life is even more difficult
than it would have been if they had
grown up in a household where both
parents were ready and willing to get
married
i agree
goku writes yo i need a wife i need to
wife a halal gym shark chick ain't no
such thing bro
ain't no such thing because you go on
jim shark's website
ain't nothing halal about gymshark and
this is not me attacking the company but
rather
the clothing industry today as a whole
and i think
i don't know this is a conspiracy theory
i have i believe that when you look at a
lot of the clothing that men and women
wear today especially women
they found a way to keep the prices the
same but use less fabric
you feel me so from a strictly financial
cost of production supply point of view
it's a phenomenal marketing strategy and
and financial strategy to to market
clothes that aren't even close
right because what are they really
clothing nothing and
thirty dollars for a little you know two
inches square of fabric
this looks like you're in a very
compromised position bro how do you feel
with that
so
it's not about getting a halal gym shark
chick
it's actually about learning how to
really work out yourself because if you
learn everything the ins and outs
yourself then once you do get married to
a woman a proper muslim
then you
can train her you can show her and by
you training her and showing her the way
then she can develop into
um i'm not gonna say what you want
because you know this we shouldn't be
doing this far enough so please you know
check your intention when you're saying
something like this
but really like you know learn yourself
and then once you do get married
then you know you can help her out and
she'll develop in a way where you will
be
very very happy with what you see
insha'allah
take the mic boy
get this on my face
[Music]
uh we're gonna take two more questions
insha allah
not in the order of first come first
serve but in the order of quality
you know we definitely got some work to
do
okay
big shout out to anthony
for the tunnel super chat so happy to
see my he's finally together
quality is superb you remember anthony
or no
and westbrook of course bro of course
yeah it's because yeah and was bb um
because romney can't see the camera so
you didn't see your dp everyone
remembers and was and was bb and was
fitness bb something like that and uh
bromela bless you even more quality
superb can't wait to see more content
inshaallah do each of you have a
favorite quran verse
allah bro
for asking what do you think
i'm probably gonna butcher this
so whoever
can um
recite this better than me please chime
in
uh but it's
which basically means um every soul
shall taste death
that's my favorite one
man i'm still thinking the only one i
can think of is
i don't know if it's all one verse or a
few verses
my believing servants who have sinned or
transgressed against themselves you know
by committing sins
do not despair in the mercy of allah
indeed allah forgives all sins and it is
him who is the most forgiving most
merciful
alhamdulillah bro how about you
the path of those who
yeah
not not who have earned your anger i
really like the ayah in the quran
because and and the whole surah as as a
whole because the opening the mother of
the quran subhanallah but i love that
ayah in the quran because
allah has told us so many times
time and time and again which is in and
of itself is is not even like he didn't
even notice this right
but all the people all the examples
and how how their actions their enough
their ego has led to their demise
all the nations that allah has destroyed
right that's why i love the not those
who have earned you this favor right
because
it's not that we're left here
willy-nilly to find out life and figure
it like allah has given us such a favor
that we know what those who have earned
his this this pleasure in this favor
have done so how now after knowing all
this can we now conduct ourselves in a
manner that's not congruent to what
allah wants from us
and for our own best interest too you
know
but wonderful question bro one more
someone when is on how's the recitation
channel coming up that's not a legit
question come on no
let's see
last one guys we'll make we'll make sure
it's a good one
okay last question bishop
brother enis writes i've become almost
careless because of my circumstances
it's hard for me to care i feel
any advice so i'm going
how to feed you feel bro can you can you
elaborate on that a little bit just so
we can we can get some context on that
because
do you mean like life has become numb
yeah without without exposing any sins
bro
samir writes when is gabriel romani
coming back to talk about intimacy bro
sooner than you think bro we'll leave it
at that inshallah
i want you to answer this while we get
some more context for that question
h writes what's your vision for the
podcast what impact specifically do you
want it to have man very good beautiful
question
i mean i can only speak for myself but
i'm sure the brothers answers will
overlap i'm going to say allah generally
just to bring as many people to islam as
possible
my goal is to clear up misconceptions
show that muslims aren't some radical
crazy cuckoo people from the middle east
that actually and remind people that
most of the amazing things that people
love about the west you know the
advancements and science and technology
and mathematics and
architecture as well even though people
don't love that about the west
architecture as well the law the legal
system the jury system innocence
approving guilty um child child support
or the child support from the government
not from the the father that's already
in islam as well but all these things
come from islam i want people to know
that and i want these
hateful spiteful non-muslims to sit here
in their anger knowing that and i want
the muslims who don't know to know that
so they can feel proud about themselves
and the ignorant people who don't know
to know that so that they can inquire
about islam and come to islam insha
allah that's my goal
okay
bro
i couldn't think of anything after i saw
this one question
asked over here so
nice i still got my answer
my my vision for this podcast is
and i don't want this to come off come
across arrogant but
keep in mind guys we're still nobody and
we're still learning ourselves right
but alhamdulillah we've learned a thing
or two in the last couple months and
years that we believe can you know help
those that are
just beginning the religious journey
their spiritual journey
and i believe that there's a lot of
misinformation out here today
subhanallah yesterday
uh me on rami we went to the gym and
there was a beautiful brother mashallah
i'm not gonna name his name beautiful uh
libyan brother and he was speaking to us
and he was like bro i don't know what to
do there's
i go on youtube and there's this one
saying this and then there's another
chef saying that and there's drama here
and there's beef there and i don't know
you know who to follow you know and he
was he was genuinely concerned because
he's like i don't know who to watch i
watched this one sheikh and this other
sheikh and this one was in this other
imam and i don't know who to follow
because all of them have contradicting
sometimes views uh on some things you
know of course there's a lot of
clear-cut things that all of us are
unanimous on but there's a lot of little
nuances that people differ in their
views
and i told them this bro that you know
wisdom is the last trait of the believer
right today
that we must take good where we can find
it and i don't want someone taking this
out of context but you know
there's only so much you could do that
for and i i my vision my personal thing
with what i want us to do us to
inshallah with this podcast is to create
an environment a community a platform
where we give people at least the basics
you know not not some advanced stuff yet
but at least the basics to get them
started guide them to the truth not
forcefully you know there's no
compulsion in deen we all know that but
guide them present the evidences just
like brother rami said in a very simple
and comprehensive manner so they're not
left confused at least they're left at
least more eased than when we found them
my goal and inshallah our goal is not to
get them to like a level of being a
scholar overnight no one can do that
even no one's going to be there but at
least we lead them and guide them with
the fundamentals in a simple way because
today i see too much misinformation even
with the fundamentals bro i see a lot of
uh you know subhanallah there's uh the
ahmadi community has bought the domain
of al-islam.com
i believe or dot org
and when you type islam or anything
about islam
their the search engine optimization has
been in a way where their their stuff
comes first
and i don't i just don't want someone to
you know be interested about islam they
find this website from them saying the
five basic pillars of islam they go and
then they're before they know they're
into kuffar
i just don't want that you know what i
mean
so at least the basic akita stuff the
basic fundamentals i want to create you
know my vision for this is just so that
the basic stuff is there in a very
comprehensive and truthful way
amongst this whole misinformation that
we have
yeah i'd say
just to add on to all that
uh my vision for this podcast is for it
to be
south of kajariya for us
and
[Music]
inshallah may be
one of the things if not the thing that
brings us into jannah allah i mean i
mean
i mean
brother gives me context
numb to insults and become numb in
general yeah i want to change but i feel
stuck and can't move further because of
myself i guess but i try
i'm not sure i really understand
maybe
oh well in that case
maybe
look at how much time you spend on
electronics
get off all the electronics spend more
time with yourself spend more time with
allah make dua
make salah
and just reflect more
and allah will
provide you everything yeah
a lot of the time people when they go
through something tragic they shut off
completely
so you probably have been through
something that you don't want to face
and because you don't want to face you
completely shut off it's very common for
a lot of people do people mostly do it
in relationships if they've been hurt
and you know and love and suffer and uh
friendships if their friends have
betrayed them they shut off but you
don't want to do that instead you should
face it one hundred percent sit meditate
reflect on it but do it from a
perspective where you know that allah is
in charge and he's in control and that
like at the very least if this was
something that was completely bad for
you allah will expect sins for you going
through it now allah will give you some
kind of reward for you just going
through it and at the very best
insha'allah this was actually something
that saved you from a greater evil maybe
you were in a relationship
maybe you tried to make a halal and then
it went sideways and you're very hurt
about it well maybe allah protected you
from having you know sex outside of
marriage having a child
you know ruining your life someone
else's life allahu adam so whatever it
is that you are hiding from face it's
insha allah with allah
foreign can't even came and go like that
or someone's
[Music]
here we go